♪ [music)] ♪
Give me one minute
and I'll show you how Composer
can help you automate
your workflows quickly.
Cloud Composer is a managed
Apache Airflow service
that helps you create, schedule, monitor
and manage workflows.
Composer workflows
can connect data processing and services
in Google Cloud, other public clouds
and on premise environments.
Because it is built upon
open-source Apache Airflow,
users are free from lock-in and benefit
from the communities' active
and rich library
of connectors and plugins.
Interacting with Composer is easy.
You can user the Cloud Console,
GCloud command line tool,
or user the API
with client libraries of your choice.
Start by creating a composer environment
where you configure your pipeline
with directed acyclic graphs.
A dag defines the tasks and dependencies
that are part of your workflow
and is written using Python.
Deploy your workflow and then monitor it
in the Airflow UI and in Cloud monitoring.
Use Composer to orchestrate
your ETL pipelines that process data
in your data warehouse and data lake.
Or, use it to automate analytics
and machine learning jobs.
So next time you're looking to configure
and orchestrate workflows,
take a minute to look at Composer.
To learn more,
checkout cloud.google.com/composer.